no i mean we didn't like grow up like
that yeah and that's why i think the
older generation they didn't grow up
with social media
so they're like why don't you just say
your opinions yeah we're like i've seen
every influencer get cancelled since
2010
we're saying the wrong thing like cancel
culture is so big it's like what is the
wrong thing is the wrong thing something
that you don't agree with so that makes
it wrong
and so all these other people that agree
with me are wrong as well i should this
is what i've noticed actually
whenever i see a clip and i get kind of
like offended by it
it's because the shoe fits a little bit
yeah
and what i've noticed is that the more
like like the angrier someone gets it's
because the shoe fits
and
yeah that's that's what i've i've
noticed i feel like there is some cases
where cancel culture hack has has been
good because it's like pedophiles i'll
give them
we can cancel pedophiles
case that happened in the summer um some
guy that was gonna be like a record
label guy he his girlfriend like posted
videos of her him abusing her and um he
was about to like get a big record label
deal and she posted it like just before
he was about to do that and like there
was videos of her like screaming and
crying and everyone's like
do you think do you think that's okay to
cancel him without going to court i feel
like because because you have no idea if
she was hitting hitting him first a lot
of people yeah like because it's like
the timing was a bit
like
yeah yeah yeah time's a bit crazy but
then at the same time if it is true that
he what like if he's gone to court and
he actually was like beating her and
stuff it's like
he doesn't well who i might say he
doesn't deserve what he's worked hard
for but i just feel like
that's the consequences of the actions
that you've done well i think it's i
think it's cool like to cancel someone
if they're found guilty but a lot of
times like the media becomes public
opinion yeah and it's like the court the
court of public opinion isn't always
correct
and the media can as well
what sometimes that's the court of law
as well no that's true
whatever the court thinks is true if
it's truth but but the problem is in the
u.s it's like it's pretty hard to
convict someone of something like it's
like because the u.s
it's it's innocent no no you are no kid
no you're right that's true there's like
money like someone gets a good lawyer
they can get out of something but like
like i i've like gone to i've like
pressed charges again it's harder than
you think i'll say something from back
in the day
a person's name and i was like let me
not say that
um
so i don't know i just think like it's
easier like to post a video and paint
someone as something than it is to
convict someone yeah it's never it's
never going to be perfect right and
you never know how true and i'm not i'm
not
discrediting the situation but we often
we often
like
when it comes to
women
there's like a
well like
what happened and i don't know if that
would be vice versa like if it was if
she was going into um a big record
label and had like a contract or
whatever and she was about to blow up
and he posted a video
uh
would we question like well like why why
now
does that make sense i think
like we have believe all women
i'm like i'm like i don't understand
cause there's some crazy ass [ __ ]
yeah that will purposely that will
purposely and i'm not i'm not saying
that that was her yeah
they would purposely put themselves in
certain positions to ruin
someone's
complete life like um there was
um a boy years ago he
was supposed to be a top prospect for a
college no it was either for a college
or to go pro
and this um girl wasn't the one that we
talked about that one time but this girl
said that um
she he like
i don't know what the word is that one
right grape there you go raped her and
his dreams were shattered and then years
later it comes to find out that it
wasn't even him or the situation didn't
even happen and it's like
how do we how do we get to that
what wouldn't why why do we just believe
hearsay she's
like
why and that's but that's even like what
we do with videos because you have no
idea what happened before like she could
have hit him over the head with the
chair before the video and then he
freaked out yeah
personally
if i was a man that someone hit me over
the channel who you are i'm knocking you
i'm rocking you across the face